It's a pleasure to welcome to the program
today.
Rachel piter Copper, who is an election forecaster
and analyst and a senior fellow at the Niskanen
Center.
Rachel, it's so great to have you on.
Yeah, it's great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
So let's get right into it.
So I've sort of intuitively suspected for
some time that at least there's a strategy
for winning elections.
Convincing people to change their minds about
who they're going to vote for is less efficient
than just finding people that agree with you
and getting them to go out and vote.
And you wrote a piece a little while ago where
you are, as I understand it, essentially supporting
the idea of a turnout strategy rather than
rather than a debate and change people's minds
strategy being a key to winning elections.
Am I correctly interpreting your perspective
and talk a little bit about how you formed
this idea?
Yeah.
I mean, you are and it's it's precipice on
this idea of a changed electorate.
Right.
So this idea that in the age of polarization,
it's exceedingly difficult to get people to
change their minds and that we have a much
better and more sophisticated understanding
of electoral behavior and voter opinions than
we did back in the days.
It certainly doesn't advocate for an either
or.
I'm not a either or black or white individual
in any capacity of my life or my research.
So I'm not saying you ignore persuasion.
I would argue it's probably most effective
amongst that small group of pure independents,
even probably would argue its efficacy against
like if you're a Democrat, trying to get an
independent that leans towards Republicans
to vote for you would be a stretch, let alone
a self-identified Republican.
But so I'm not saying you shouldn't do persuasion
at all.
But, you know, until recently, Democrats pretty
much engaged in almost entirely and devoting
their resources towards persuading spending
geo TV money and their ad strategy and their
messaging and framing over this idea of convincing
voters of the other party or voters that don't
agree with them to vote for them.
And I am arguing that they neglected to consider
shaping the electorate in their image the
way that the Republicans have.
How have the Republicans done it and what
sorts of strategies work or can you use to
do that?
Yeah.
So the way that Republicans have done it primarily
is through effective, you know, research based
messaging strategies.
So when you look at how a Republican run,
a Republican run campaign talks to voters
like they kind of meet the voter where they
are, and you can't say that Democrats are
as good at that.
And it's not a flattering place where the
American voter is.
Unfortunately, Americans are not particularly
civically minded or engaged.
Even the part that is engaged in elections
tend to be pretty poorly informed.
So, you know, Democrats tend to have an idealized
version of voters.
They tend to think that voters want a very
wonky policy based discussion, you know, and
hit them with these types of mailers that
are, you know, pointing out, well, Republicans
want to do this with, you know, abortion funding
and we want to do that, whereas Republicans
are talking to voters emotions.
And the reason that they do that, number one,
is because people are better motivated by
emotions.
But number two, you know, if you were talking
to somebody who doesn't have a great understanding
of policy, it's probably cause they're not
much interested in it.
Right.
And so if you are hitting them with these
wonky, you know, heavily word laden policy
appeals, they're going to tune out pretty
quickly.
You want to hit them in a way that resonates
with them and conveys that information pretty
quick.
So Republicans really do certain techniques.
I'm happy to get into specific details about
that are much more effective at getting through
to that less inclined, less civically engaged
voter.
Now, my instinct is that this works better
with some issues than with others in the sense
that there are issues that naturally lend
themselves more to a more sort of visceral.
I've got to do something about that sort of
reaction.
Is that also a part of it, which is figuring
out what is a voting issue in the first place?
Yeah, I mean, that's true, right?
I mean, to some degree you can't.
To some degree you can't create salience.
But I'll push back at that a little bit, too,
because I mean, think about Benghazi.
Right.
Yeah.
How many Republicans did you run into in 2016?
That would point to especially the ones that
were like little bit less Trump like, would
you?
Trump?
And they would say, well, yeah, but Benghazi.
Right.
I mean just the.
They could name Benghazi as a.
Main issue is a testament to how much you
can actually push and mold public opinion
and voter like salience if you are effective
at it.
And you know what you're doing.
Because I wonder, I wonder, was the Benghazi
refrain actually about Benghazi?
Or was it the emotion of being repelled by
Hillary and simply finding something to say
about it?
Yeah.
I mean, yes and no.
But like me, it's such a knish issue.
But yet I still I still run into people who
say, well, I voted for Trump, but I do because
of Benghazi.
Like Democrats would tell you that such a
thing would be impossible to do.
Right.
So you know, so.
So the answer is you need to have the right
issue.
It needs to be an issue that resonates with
people.
But they you need to talk about it in the
right way.
So like Democrats will talk about health care,
but they don't make it about life and death.
I mean, sometimes they do.
And I think they're getting better about conveying,
you know, if Medicaid expansion doesn't pass,
this kid with preexisting conditions is going
to die.
Right.
That's how Republicans would talk about Medicaid
expansion if we don't pass this thing.
You're going to die.
And Democrats don't want to take it to that
level of stakes.
Right.
But that's how Republicans.
Everything is life or death.
If you don't vote for a Republican in twenty
nineteen in Virginia, they're going to take
your guns away.
It's not they're gonna make modest reforms
to the gun laws that make it so that you have
additional hurdles to clear for a gun purchase.
It's you know, they're going to take all your
guns.
And so it is a two fold problem that Democrats
have identified the right issues.
And frankly, sometimes they're decent at that.
But talking about them in a way that for you
and me, work campaigns are not about us.
Campaigns are about those people that don't
give a poop, about politics, about policy.
And the reason is that nobody is explained
to them how important that policy is to them
personally.
The stakes that those things have for them.
And, you know, we I would say or I would argue
Democrats tend to make campaigns that are
ready, designed to talk to voters that I care
about politics.
So using this model and applying it to the
2020 election, pre corona virus first and
then we'll talk about maybe what's going on
now.
How would you have assessed the likely outcome
of the election on this basis before the virus?
Well, so, you know, I mean, if you're familiar
with my research, you know, I put my forecast
out for the presidential election before the
virus.
I mean, months and months before and posted
an update based on the conclusion of the Democratic
primary, which, you know, for me, as a trained
political scientist with an expertise in presidential
nominations, new was a mathematical certainty
after the Super Tuesday contest.
And so I updated my forecast based on the
conclusion of the Democratic primary and the,
you know, an inevitability that Joe Biden
would be the nominee.
And I talked a little bit about how I could
not yet account for effects of the pandemic
and the economic collapse that's going to
accompany it, but also said that I'm not sure
that it's going to matter all that much and
in the forecast for Congress that I released
tomorrow.
So, you know, shameless plug, my congressional
forecast that's been long awaited and much
anticipated is going to be dropped tomorrow.
Yes.
Hold on.
Getting interrupted by a kid, which is like
a quintessential pandemic at such a key moment
as well.
Now, the you know, the Congress forecast is
going to talk.
Okay.
Now we're further a month further down the
road.
And like I anticipated, the pandemic has not
moved the public opinion about Donald Trump
at all.
Like we are a public that is completely incapable
of responding to massive political stimulus
because of polarization and hyper partisanship.
We also said when you asked me, you know,
is it gonna be before or after?
And there's not to be much difference, to
tell you the truth right now.
And where do you see it?
Yeah.
And that forecast anticipates a very good
election cycle for Democrats, given that Democrats
and independents, especially, you know, left
leaning independents, of which there are a
great deal of, and especially in this audience,
I would guess, because when we think about
who or independents, they are disproportionately
younger voters and they're disproportionately
white demographically.
But anyway, left leaning independents and
also pure independents and people who don't
lean who broke for Trump in 2016.
But my research predicts we'll probably vote
in favor of the Democrat.
Cycle.
And I think the one area that the forecast
might change a little bit is I think that
that trumps problem with pure independents
has probably been compounded by the pandemic
and the economic collapse because he is not
a great leader, as you know, objectively.
You know, if you were to say, OK, how is Trump
handling the crisis?
And you led laid out a set of metrics that
you would want a leader to meet in terms of
this particular crisis and the things that
internationally luckily, this is a crisis
that we can do that with because it's a crisis
that the world shares.
Right.
So you have a set of objective standards that
are put forward by health policy professionals.
And the United States is failing very poorly,
preparing fairly poorly at these standards
objectively.
And I think that is going to probably impact
that pure independent voting bloc a little
bit in the election.
Now, in terms of Trump's approval not being
affected, it does look like, according to
the Gallup tracking poll, we saw the largest
decline in approval between takes, so to speak,
a nine point decline, which we've not seen
during the presidency.
It's still within the same range, right.
It's still not a new number that we haven't
seen before.
But the precipitous decline seems novel.
But you don't really think that it's moving
dramatically in a substantive way.
Yeah.
So another advantage I think that I can bring
to forecasting in the election analysis is
that I am, I believe, the only forecast or
any way and like race handicapper that also
doubled as a as an active and, you know, really
experienced pollster.
So I spent five years running polls, many,
many, many polls.
So I'm a very well versed in polling methodology.
And so it pains me to say that something has
been going weird in the Gallup poll for the
last couple of years, really.
And I haven't been including it.
I'm I do a very different model than the traditional
method used by Silver.
And many of the other analysts is to throw
every poll into a model because, you know,
oh, it will the noise will get canceled out
if you just aggregate them off.
Whereas I am actually a very snobby poll digester.
I do want more than one poll.
I'm not big on one poll, but I also will not
include polls that seemed that have certain
methodologies that have low end sizes like
it means basically the poll has a low end
side.
I don't even look at the results of this.
You know, at some point we'll put out a guide
to poll watching for people to follow, because
actually it is astounding to me, like how
many really, really big name people use polling
data in a way that is actually statistically
inappropriate.
So, you know, polling is interesting, but
yeah.
So we look at Trump's polling data using decent
data.
What we will see is that there was a two or
three point rally around the flag effect.
Yes.
And the untrained eye during that week of
this was like, oh, look, Trump has a rally
around the flag effect.
He's getting more popular.
But a trend I looked at it mine and said,
oh, god, look at this.
Like this is the most amazing, muted rally
around the flag effect we've ever seen in
presidential politics.
It's completely atypical.
We should see a 10, 15, 20.
I mean, really like for this crisis, this
type of crisis, something that's completely
externally caused, it's, you know, what we
would call without blame.
I mean, at least in the beginning, when the
put before the public begins to realize, you
know, the decision making in the early process,
external crisis started outside of the country's
borders, something that we would have expected
prior to polarization, a twenty point rally
around the flag effect for.
And the fact that he better I mean, basically
did not get one is a real testament both to
how on popular he is personally, but also
to have powerful polarization, hyper partisanship.
Ah, in American politics right now.
And, you know, I'll be talking quite a bit
about this in this congressional forecast
that comes out tomorrow.
So on the radio, TV show and podcast, we're
going to go to a break.
We'll have our full conversation with Rachel
on the YouTube channel
So looking back at presidential approval with
George W. Bush, for example, at 9/11, his
approval went to close to 90 at the start
of the Iraq war.
It went to 71.
And that was not a situation we had no control
over.
It was a decision and a choice to go to war.
So those would be the data points.
You would compare to, say, the three or four
points.
Trump God is just very small in comparison
for a rally around the president.
Yeah, I mean, personally, I consider it a
non effect, not effect.
OK, fair enough.
So let me ask you this.
There there are a lot of people who e-mail
me and who have been e-mailing me throughout
the primary saying only X candidate, if they
were to be the nominee, could defeat Donald
Trump in November.
And typically, the sort of names that are
included there were either Bernie Sanders,
Andrew Yang or Tulsi Gabbard.
Those were the three whose followers seemed
more likely to e-mail me and say, this is
the only person that can beat Trump.
Would your analysis be fundamentally different
if, for example, Bernie Sanders were the nominee
instead of Joe Biden in this particular case?
Yeah.
So here is where the Sanders nomination was
would be different is that Democrats are not
Republicans.
So when Donald Trump executed a hostile ideological
takeover and his type take over, I mean, that's
kind of weird, right?
It's got elements of a far right takeover,
but it's also nationalist.
It is also populist.
And it forced the party into positions they
had never before considered.
And, you know, it also forced them into some
very, you know, problematic positions on race
and things like that.
But you know what?
Sanders had he won the nomination.
It would have been via a could probably a
brokered conventions because of the heat as
it played out anyway.
He didn't he wasn't winning big delegate count
contests.
Right.
And so what would have happened, in my estimation,
is Democratic.
You know, other candidates running in the
Senate, running in the House would have freaked
out because they don't have the.
I'm so sorry.
Gabby is going to have to get kicked out of
here real quick.
Gabe, sounds like it looks like it's snowing
in there, all of you.
I need you to leave.
Yeah, we're fine.
We'll get to that.
Not on TV.
All right.
We'll have to roll in the agent.
Yes, indeed.
Yes.
In any way.
You know, with with my estimation is I think
what would happen is the Republicans, too.
They would have been very shrewd and pushing
this.
The party's establishment is convinced and
I know the Sanders crowd is convinced it's
about corporatism and corruption.
But I it actually comes from a genuine belief
that a Sanders type candidate would not win
election.
And that's because, you know, these candidates
and that's the party's mainstream consultant
class and election class is wholeheartedly
convinced that their path to electoral winning
must run through conversion of Republican
voters for some reason.
Right now, Republicans don't have to somehow
win election ever by converting Democrats.
And there's more Democrats.
But somehow Democrats must win office by converting
Republicans.
And because of that, then if you have a nominee
who is a self-described socialist, then you
have sentenced yourself to electoral loss.
All right.
So what's the claim from Simon?
That's right.
It's not a claim.
It's a deep seeded belief.
They all believe it.
So it's not about corporatism or defending
the corporate structures.
And really, I mean, you know, what it is is
about, OK?
They think that Bernie Sanders is unelectable
and that by putting them on the ticket, they
would be sentencing, you know, the party to
four more years of Trump and costing all these
other candidates their races.
And they believe that Sanders people listening
to this just as deeply as you believe the
things that you believe in.
So, you know, if you could put yourself into
another person's shoes, that's really important
because that will help you understand.
My next point.
My next point is because they have that deep
seated belief, what they would do.
And they're not Republicans.
So they're not they're not the kind of people
that will say, OK, you know, this is the guy,
though, that we've been handed.
And the only way that we can have any shot
of winning is to stay in line, basically.
Right.
The Republican Party did, you know, in some
ways fracture at times around Trump.
You had the Access Hollywood video came out
and Republicans were like, I'm not going to,
you know, he should step out.
And we had some moments where the party freaked
out.
But by and large, elites did coalesce around
him.
Now, they didn't they didn't, you know, go
to the convention and endorse him and give
speeches on his behalf.
But they didn't fight him.
Right.
They did not run against their own party.
So like the Democratic campaign would have
played out in 2018, where like Mark Kelly
in Arizona, for example, would have been running
two campaigns at once, he would've been running
a campaign against Trump, which is a referendum
campaign that's very effective and is the
one that my model predicts Democrats will
win.
The problem is he would also be running a
campaign against socialism and Republicans
would artfully, because they're so much better
at strategy B, forcing and tricking them into
devoting as much time and resource into that
campaign as possible, because that's a campaign
Republicans think that they can win A and
B, that's a campaign that diverts resources
and attention away from the campaign and Republicans
know they will lose, which is a referendum
on Trump.
So let me make sure I understand that.
So if Bernie were the nominee and you had
today Mark Kelly running against Martha McSally
in Arizona, Mark Kelly would be running against
Martha McSally as a referendum on Trump with
because McSally is more associated with Trump.
But simultaneously, Kelly would have to be
distancing from the Bernie Sanders model.
Yes.
Right.
Not as not as this Democrat said that.
So remember when I said that people make the
mistake of assuming everyone's like them?
Yes.
And here, if you're listening to this show
in any capacity, I have really great news
for you.
You're in the 1 percent, not the economic
1 percent, OK?
You're in the politically engaged into intellectual
1 percent.
And that means that you are a particularly
terrible frame of reference by which to judge
anything about other people because you are
the crumbed of the crown.
You are the smartest, most engaged, most passionate
and most interested by the American voter
out there.
You could probably tell me 10, maybe 20 of
the Democratic candidates that ran in this
primary where the modal American voter and
not even the ones that set out the elections,
but the one that will actually vote in November,
can only tell me maybe Biden and Warren Globish
are Bhuta Jej and Sanders.
That would be the extent of their repertoire
of like your average, you know, blue or white
collar.
So non-college-educated or college educated,
average American.
OK, like that.
So we are not good people to think about how
how average like the average bell curve of
the electorate does things.
And so.
So that's where Birdee like this is where
I have argued.
Progressives actually had a moment here in
this cycle that was that they had a really
a good moment for the message, but they had
a really problematic messenger because the
party is so is so spooked about people who
have the specific label of socialist.
And Bernie is so much video that, you know,
that it was very easy to spoof these mainstream
candidates into thinking that they would get
dragged down by his candidacy.
So you so if you're asking me like my forecast
tomorrow that people are going to really want
to look at.
Yes, it would look different if Bernie Sanders
was going to be the nominee because, A, he
would be getting that nomination sometime
now in August by a brokered convention, assuming
this pandemic still happens.
In other words, he'd be earning it having
earned a plurality of the delegates winning
the most out of everybody, but not a majority
enough to secure the nomination.
And that does not indicate consensus right
in the party.
And number two, because I would assume that
the party wouldn't spend as much time running
against itself as running against Trump because
of the socialist problem.
Now, it's possible that Democrats, especially,
you know, having my research publicly available,
where I make this point clear and I've been
making this point clear for about two years,
that the danger isn't so much the candidate
it as it is the party's belief that the candidate
is unelectable.
But, you know, my assumption is, yes, that.
You know, that division of message would probably
cost them.
You know something, you know some electoral
ground.
Yeah.
Rachel, it's an absolute pleasure to talk
to you.
And we will be very excitedly awaiting that
assessment tomorrow.
We've been speaking with Rachel Bittar Coffer,
who's an election forecaster, analyst and
senior fellow at the Niskanen Center.
Rachel, really appreciate your time today.
Thanks so much for having me.
And then please follow me on Twitter and do
a lot of everyday commentary there.